[Music]
about five about 10-14 probably about 15
each woman owns an average of 6.5 bras
Basah thing
but they want more bras and better bras
in this room new bras are born just
outside of New York City is Maiden Farms
prototype design lab veteran bra is on
Iran de is attempting to design an
extremely lightweight bra
it must be supportive comfortable
attractive and virtually weightless
using pre shaped foam cups reduces the
amount of stitching needed to create the
bras shape every stitch that can be
eliminated means a lighter bra women's
breasts can vary from 10 ounces to 20
pounds and this 4 ounce bra has to
support them all it's time to give the
fabric for the cups that's special
something in the molding room the
stretchy material for the cups gets
molded by a press featuring a pair of
shapely steel patru branches that are
hot 405 degrees
the heat and pressure ensures the
material holds its shape measurements
are taken to ensure accuracy there is no
room for error in a prototype next stop
the stitch room this bra is made up of
12 pieces of fabric of two molded cups a
hook and eye clasp two plastic rings and
two slides double stitching is key to
reinforcing the parts of the bra that
will be under the most strain the trick
here is to make the bra strong without
making it bulky a few thousand stitches
later this prototype is ready back to
Wanda the bra that Wanda envisioned is
now in her hands but this is only the
beginning just because a prototype looks
good on a bust form doesn't mean it can
stand up to the demands of a real woman
the true test is a fitting with a live
model we're checking to make sure the
light bra is fitting the way we want it
to fit so we have a 34b model here the
only way to really get a good fit into
check it is to use live models
[Music]
so the measurements are good maybe it's
just the way we sewed that tuff and the
size around is good Oksana we just see
the back a fit models job is to be very
vocal about where the bra feels good and
where it doesn't this bracket is much
more lighter okay it feels flattering
right because the back is made I'm
obliged I think it's great so we're
almost finished with this particular bra
but not quite it will take around 20
rounds of changes to perfect this bra
each change requested by the fit model
can affect other aspects of bra
sometimes solving one problem creates
three new ones and five fit models are
used for each new design altogether it
takes 50 people in seven departments
over six months to lock in the design of
one new bra
[Music]